try to pull the company and have it
succeed is like eating glass and staring
into the abyss I think that really the
way to sell any product is through word
of mouth you know where you put your
blood sweat and tears into creating
something a bully something it's like a
child
Juanes or get a mentor
[Music]
so today let's learn from one of the
best Elon Musk and some of his best
business tips mentor me Elon okay let's
kick it off with rule number one
generate word-of-mouth how aside from
making great products how do you get
people excited about Tesla there's a lot
of people I know and that I talked to
who are just intrigued and interested
and excited about Tesla as a company
the thing that really focus on at Tesla
is the grid put all the money into and
attention into trying to make the
product as compelling as possible so
because I think that the really the way
to sell any product is through
word-of-mouth
so if a warrant for somebody gets the
car they really like it they and
actually the key is like to have a
product that people love and journal
you'll the if that a party or toward
friends whatever you'll talk about the
things that you love but if you just
like something it's okay you're not
gonna care that much but if you love
reactions from the highs and the lows
really I'm gonna it's you're gonna talk
you know and and then that'll generate
returns word of mouth and that's
basically how our sales have grown like
we don't we're not spending money on
advertising or endorsements or and so
anywhere like fives our card they just
order because they they like the car and
you know it's like it's genuine rule
number two take risks one of the most
difficult choices I have ever faced in
life was was in 2008 and I think I had
like maybe thirty million dollars left
thirty or forty one dollars left in 2008
I had two choices I could put it all
into one company and then the other
company would definitely die or split it
between the two companies and but if I
split it between two companies then both
might die and you know when you put your
blood sweat and tears into creating
something a bully something it's like a
child
and so it's like which one am I gonna
let one starve to death I can bring
myself to do it
but I split the money between two
fortunately thank goodness they both
came through also if you want to learn
how to have more confidence check out my
254 series it's free the link is in the
description below there are times when
something is important enough you
believe it enough that you do it in
spite of the fear rule number 3 have a
high pain tolerance there's a friend of
mine he's got a great thing about
creating a company which is creative
trying to ball the company and have it
succeed is like eating glass and staring
into the abyss so I mean what tends
happen is it's sort of quite exciting
for the first several months of starting
a company and then then reality sets in
things don't go as well as planned
customers aren't signing up the
technology part isn't working as well as
you thought and and then can that
concerns be compounded by a recession
and it can be very very painful for
several years so I think frankly
starting a company you advise people to
have a high pain tolerance rule number
four don't let failures stop you what
was your biggest failure and how did it
change you it's a really think hard
about that failure there's your answer
well there's a ton of failures along the
way that's for sure like I said as a
support for SpaceX the first three
launches failed and we were just barely
able to scrape together enough parts and
money to do the fourth launch that both
launch had failed we would have been
dead so multiple failures along the way
I tried very hard to get the right
expertise in for for SpaceX I tried hard
to to find a great chief engineer for
the rocket but it but the good Chief
Engineers wouldn't join and the bad ones
well there was no no point in hiring
them so I ended up a chief engineer at
the rocket
so if I could have found somebody better
then we would have maybe had less than
three failures and rule number five the
last one before a very special bonus
clip is don't rely on wishful thinking
young people globally want to be like LM
moss what's your advice with it I think
that probably they shouldn't want to be
hey you I think it sounds better than it
is okay yeah it's not as much fun being
me as you'd think
I don't know you don't think so yeah
this definitely it could be worse for
sure but it's I I I'm not sure I would
I'm not sure I want to be me
but if you know I think advice I mean if
you want to make progress and things I
think that but the the best analytical
framework for us and in the future is
physics
I'd recommend studying the the thinking
process around physics like but not just
not the equations I mean the equation is
certainly they're helpful but the the
way of thinking in physics is the that's
the best framework for understanding
things that are counterintuitive and and
you know always taking the position that
you are some degree wrong and your goal
is to be less wrong over time the one of
the biggest mistakes people generally
make and I'm guilty of a two is wishful
thinking you know like you want
something to be true even if it isn't
true and so you ignore the things that
you ignore the real truth because of
what you want to be true this is a very
difficult trap to avoid and like I said
certainly one that I find myself in
having prawns with but if you just take
that approach of your oyster some degree
wrong and your goal is to be less wrong
and and solicit critical feedback
particularly from friends like your
friends particularly friends if somebody
loves you they want the best for you
they don't want to tell you the bad
things so you have to ask them okay you
know it said really I really do want to
know and and then they'll tell you now
I've got a special bonus cut from Elon
Musk on how to be willing to make
sacrifices that I really think you can
enjoy but before that it's time for the
three point landing questions let's go
from just watching a video to taking
action here we
go question number one what failure is
stopping you that you need to get over
number two what new risk do you need to
take this week number three what five
strategies will you apply this month to
generate more word-of-mouth
I mean Tesla really face this fear
threat threat of death due to the model
3 production ramp essentially the
company was bleeding money like crazy
and and just if we didn't solve these
problems in a very short period of time
we would die and it was extremely
difficult to solve them how close to
death did you come we're within single
digit weeks 22 hours a day I think what
I mean I was working answer seven days a
week sleeping in the factory worked away
from the I work from the paint shop
general assembly body shop you ever
worry about yourself imploding like it
just yeah absolutely no one should put
those many hours into work this is not
good you feel should not work this hard
I don't look they should not do this it
was very painful painful in what sense
it's because my hurts my brain and my
heart hurts this is not recommended for
anyone I just did it because if I didn't
do it and Tesla group chat says would I
if you want to learn how to be the next
Elon Musk check out the video right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there I must spend a lot of time with
media or on business see things but
actually almost almost all my time 80%
of it is spent on engineering design